nun wird sie die da sagen okay ich mache
also älter bist du das continental ag
jetzt wird's richtig geisteskrank
ich habe heute einen blick in meine in
study 1 geworfen und habe gesehen dass
ihr mir sehr sehr viele sehr ähnliche
nachrichten geschickt habt diese
nachrichten laut zb könntest du auf
dieses video reagieren es ist einfach so
schlecht gemacht
ich frage mich die menschen so etwas
überhaupt noch glauben können oder auch
einfach fünfmal facebook
ich wollte der ganze sache dann
natürlich auf den grund gehen auch auf
den link geklickt den immer geschickt
habt und tada es geht um ein video von
rebecca wir uns mal den namen des videos
anschauen leute kommen wir sehr schnell
zu dem entschluss dass für bekkering
scheinbar gerade wieder durchdreht ich
lese sie auch mal den titel vor facetime
um drei uhr nachts niemals mit älter aus
frozen so weit geht es jetzt schon sie
kamen zu mir nach hause
ich habe eine neue verfluchte ich hab'
sie diesmal nicht selbst gefunden sollen
jemand aus dem becken hat sie gefunden
das geil sie macht das sowieso
routinemäßig zu also ich hab ja schon
ein paar videos gemacht wo ich mir
sachen von mir angeschaut habe keinerlei
auch schon ein paar über diese drei uhr
nachts mit irgendwelchen charakteren
facetime und dann kommen sie vorbei und
auch darüber habe ich schon ein paar
gemacht und ich muss sagen das ist echt
lustig wie sie einfach immer so mit der
gleichen ernsthaftigkeit immer behauptet
dass sie jetzt eine verfluchte nummer
hat leute ich bin es wieder weg ich habe
mir neue verfluchte nummer
diesmal wurde die verfluchte nummer von
team battle gefunden
auf ihr verbunden wir die nummer über
instagram dm zugeschickt und zwar ist
dass die nummer von frozen bezirks von
elser aus frozen was war das 15 schreien
lachen am ende ja zu den wahlen sind
eher so aus hier rauskommt so aber gott
sein gastiert das video noch schnell
beendet abstellen kathrein gesetz kurz
bevor so geschrieben dass der neue
verfluchten nummer gefunden hat die sich
von elsa frozen sein
ja ja ja ja da hat wohl jemand aus
teenager versuchten immer gefunden
er hat gar keinen fall leute das will
ich von keinem von euch hören
auf gar keinen fall ist es so dass
rebecca wegen diesen screenshot hier mit
dieser nachricht irgendwie gefällt hat
oder so und so tut als hätte jemand die
normal geschickt wirklich jemand hat
team bekehrte verblutet nummer gefunden
[Musik]
angezeigt das bild ab wie drin also mal
hand aufs herz ich glaube ich werde
niemals verstehen wieso sich das leute
sollte eigentlich anschauen also wie sie
schauen sich das leute bei ihr an
sollten wir wahrscheinlich denken die
wirklich dass es echt ist also so
irgendwelche kleinen kids irgendwann
deutschland so 6 oder 8 jähriger die
diese videos schauen denken
wahrscheinlich wirklich dass man elser
aus frozen per facetime anrufen kann nur
aus irgendwann kommen diese kids nicht
an die verfluchten nummern
deswegen sei gut dass wir red wing für
die da anruft nur eine schneeflocke drin
sonst nicht versteht nicht dass keine
schneeflocke drin aber okay das ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt das sympathischste
von m
da war schon wieder da wär's fast schon
wieder durchgebrochen ich glaube nämlich
dass rebecca so diese videos macht und
dass hier auch schon so auffällt wenn
sie diese videos macht so ja ich hab ein
bisschen jetzt was jetzt gerade wache so
ich bin so überholt oder tusche überhalb
darauf welchen whatsapp status elser aus
frozen hat darüber wenn sie das merkt
dann kommt einmal so ein hysterischer
lacher durch und dann hat es wieder ab
reagiert dann geht es wieder weiter
wovor dell sei eigentlich wohnt nicht in
irgend so ein königreich oder so ich
musste tatsächlich gestehen dass ich ich
kenne elsa ist figur so ich habe frau
sind selbst aber glaub ich nicht
geschaut wurde irgendwie erspart hinter
tsonga den song habe ich schon ein paar
mal eine dusche saison gewinnt weil aber
hat er sah in dem land wo sie wohnt
internet sie hat mit einer schneeflocke
geantwortet dass man sich mal vorstellen
könnte also irgend jemand sitzen dann im
anderen raum in ihrer wohnung oder so
hat ein kumpel von ihr sitzt ein haus
weiter denn die sache eingeweiht ist und
den hat sie als elsa eingespeichert hat
dann zudem abgesagt soja martin kannst
du bitte ein bild von elsa reinmachen ja
ich weiß es nicht
wir gucken wir gar auf sagt ich eine
schneeflocke
sie kann kein deutsch es ist also aus
frozen nicht elser aus gefroren durch
wahrscheinlich kann die nur englisch
oder oder halt schneeflocken awards
abschicken
ja und wer bist du es ist ein bisschen
klingt nett alles zurückzahlen war kein
elfer dort also das ganze alles ganz
normal ganz normaler tag in deutschland
eine deutsche youtube drin sitzt nachts
um drei mit ihrem smartphone und
schreibt mit dem disney charaktere auf
what's up alle alles ganz normale leute
in rebecca und jetzt auf verlangen sie
sollten mal war wieder einmal gelegt war
nicht die frage ob ich die partie für
man rufen kann das mal kurz überlegen
aber könnte ich die ich über facetime
wirklich ich habe mir das alles nicht
frage mich so wie wie geht das wie
schafft man das als mensch so
enthusiastisch zu tun
das ist für mich unvorstellbar also
wirklich ich kann mir das nicht
vorstellen wie gering das macht müsst
ihr euch geben ist ja dies ja ich sag
das mal wieder ist noch ein paar jahre
älter als ich glaube ich die 26 28 oder
sowas fast 30 wie schafft es rebecca
ring dass sie sich hinsetzt und
ernsthaft wie auch begeistert tun kann
zumindest darüber dass sie mit elsa
auslösen schreibt manche menschen sind
irgendwie anders als andere schneeflocke
schneeflocke ist ungefähr so viel wie du
kleine stalkerin löscht diese nummer
sofort ich bin nichts mehr hören ich
gedacht okay ich dran bist du das
continium fachleute wie ist es möglich
sagt mir bitte wie das möglich ist es
ist doch haarsträubend als es tut sie so
als hätte sie in facetime anrufe
bekommen von elster und die zieht die
ganze zeit einfach ihre rolle durch eine
frau ende 20 dreht auf kamera durch
darüber dass angeblich ein disney
charaktere sie auf facebook angerufen
hat in welcher welt leben wir noch mal
ich wünsche ihr könntet gerade meine
hände spielen habe ich so richtig kalt
aber ich meine ich hab ihr blaues kleid
gesehen ihr auch oder habe ich das
richtig gesehen richtig geil gefreut
nicht irgendwie kann ich die nummer
ok ok stop stop weg jetzt langsam wird
es wirklich beängstigend ok langsam
mache ich mir sorgen bist bist du
wirklich nicht dann wenn du diese videos
dreht ist sicher dass du nicht
irgendwelche substanzen in deinem system
ist irgendwas was halluzinationen
verursacht jetzt jetzt mit ihr kalt
wahrscheinlich hat also zu viele
schneeflocken aber aus abgeschickt kann
natürlich schon mal die raumtemperatur
ein bisschen senken
langsam immer kälter das alter trecker
bist du nicht bei 30 wie kannst du dich
da hinsetzen und jetzt auch noch so
erzählt dass ihr kann wird man es gibt
nicht mal die person mit der du gerade
face times
die kammer in welchem fluss jetzt wird's
richtig geisteskrank jetzt kommt der
partner elsa sie tatsächlich besuch
glaube ich beginnt natürlich damit dass
das licht ausgeht ist ist klar also
kennen wir ja mittlerweile das ist
standard wird beckham trägt wenn
irgendein personen dann angeblich kommt
dann geht das licht aus und sie ist also
mein gott ich hab das habe ich noch nie
erlebt auf gar keinen fall ist das in 40
videos für ihr schon mal passiert geht
nicht mehr an
ok hast du schon mal im sicherungskasten
abgeschaut
also wer wäre so mein erster gedanke ja
ich will nicht nichts falsches erzählt
ich habe auch nicht so viel erfahrung
damit aber wenn bei mir in der lampe
ausgeht und nicht wieder angeht wenn
mein erster gedanke also okay ich schaue
sich aus gefassten und vielleicht nicht
so aber okay ich glaube ich jetzt mal
ein disney prinzessin heimgesucht manche
menschen sind irgendwie anders
hey das hoch gelegt ich bin dafür
eingetreten da war so ein bisschen kraft
als eine möhre alter ich bin doch nicht
nur diese höhere wie traurig sie das
haus die rag hat keine kosten und mühen
gescheut und dieses video so realistisch
wie möglich aufstellen zu lassen hat ein
500 gramm beutel crushed ice von der
tankstelle genommen und eine möhre war
furchteinflößend es eis
es soll natürlich muss revidieren es ist
nicht nur 500 gramm kochsalz von der
tankstelle und eine möhre
nein es sind auch noch jetzt muss ich
festhalten ob er halte fest ich habe
mich am tisch fest es sind auch noch
zwei stücke dabei um eine karotte
hier sind zwei stücke wie geht das stück
ja okay er ist klar wusste ich auch
nicht ich dachte bis dato also die
anzahl ist stockner plural dachte ich
jetzt bis dato stücke aber auch da habe
ich wiederum falsch gelegen liegt
wahrscheinlich daran dass mein handy und
über kopf woche neben der disney
prinzessin gefälscht hat nein der plural
von stock ist stadtkern
warum geht das licht nicht mehr wer war
das
und da endet das video einfach ohne
irgendeine auflösung ohne irgendeine
einen rettungsanker an dem man sich
festhalten kann für alle menschen die
sich danach denken was ja leute und
damit endet die heutige folge von
youtube anzuschauen bei dem man sich
nicht mehr ganz sicher ist ob sie
geistig gesund sind solltet ihr in
zukunft auf youtube videos finden die
euch am sinn des lebens zweifeln lassen
zudem egal welchen vermehrte dann
schickt mir die gerne auf instagram
jackie einfach ich vorgeschlagen ist
wieder auf ihr umfeld in den kanal
abonnieren ich bin dieser stelle raus
und